depuis près d'une décennie à
lac-mégantic militants et survivance
rassemblés pour rendre hommage aux 40
les victimes de la tragédie et pour
poursuivre la revendication
[Musique]
excusé détection
cas bien que la ville sont maintenant
rebâti ici le train passe toujours
à chaque nuit moi je me faire réveiller
par des convois de trains qui descendent
latentes sur la compression des
locomotives on entend c'est un bruit
infernal et on ne sait pas s'ils vantent
capable de retourner
au centre-ville la courbe
en moyenne une trentaine de stern de gaz
propane l'acide sulfurique de chlorate
de sodium qui excelle à blanchir le
parti dans les moulins pepy c'est très
toxique il pense déjà aux automobiles on
est très très très conscients des petits
danger imminent qui entend rester à
lac-mégantic
les matières dangereuses comme le
pétrole brut qui a rasé le centre ville
de lac-mégantic représente un risque
partout où elles se trouvent mais ces
produits qui sillonnent les chemins de
fer et non repris qui sont stockés
partout sur notre territoire sont
pourtant essentiels
du nitrate d'ammonium pour fertiliser
les champs du propane pour chauffer les
granges et séchez les grains du chlore
pour purifier l'eau de l'ammoniac pour
la réfrigération et les produits
pétroliers pour à peu près tout le reste
ce sont des matières qui font partie de
notre quotidien mais qui lorsqu'elles
sont mal gérées peuvent causer des
catastrophes
[Musique]
les versions majeures font les
manchettes il y a aussi souvent des
instants qui frôle la catastrophe et qui
passe sous leurs abords c'est quoi la
suite ans
non
on a
une collision frontale
le contente
[Musique]
des accidents qui s'enchaînent et des
erreurs qui se répète en raison d' un
cafouillis réglementaire qui sème la
confusion et entretient le pas citer
parce qu on est frileux ici au canada on
apprend des tas l'artiste
essaie d'éviter de parler de ces
matières l'otan c'est le souvenir que
j'ai de cette nuit là c'est vraiment des
tables sont un passé proche qu'on savait
même pas qui avait de l'ammoniac sur les
habits étaient des égouts puis avaient
du gaz propane faire que
sans l'appui une allumette remettons une
table de scarlett o'hara pu faire sauter
sauter de blanc une partie du bureau
juin est-ce que vous avez déjà vu des
inspecteurs d'environnement canada aux
transports canada ici non en 45 ans de
carrière non non
[Musique]
le seesus du rêve
de lac mégantic le théâtre d'une des
plus grandes catastrophes ferroviaires
de l'histoire du canada
j'avançais de lac-mégantic plus je
voyais la fumée au loin c'était visible
de très très loin on la voyait de
prendre kilomètres de distance
facilement hélas c'est là que tu rentres
dedans c'était possible qu'il ait pas de
mort la donne
ancien attaché politique et travailleur
social robert del flare il devenu un des
plus ardents défenseurs de sa commune
pour ceux sans oublier par le
gouvernement canadien ce seront nous
promène voir contournement mais ça fait
huit ans qu'on l'attend
imaginez vous la rvm à montréal qui est
annoncée bien après l'avoir quand on ma
main va être terminé avant le pont
champlain étaient construits dont on n'a
même pas encore une pelletée de terre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce sentiment d'être oubliés faisons
beaucoup à lac mégantic surtout qu'il
n'ya jamais une enquête publique nous on
arrête là manquaient tous les cas toutes
les haines on la trouve nécessaire
indispensable
d'abord pour les familles ici qui ont
perdu des êtres chers qui ne savent
varier d qui est responsable
quelles sont les causes
le bureau de la sécurité des transports
du canada a blâmé la faible culture de
sécurité de la compagnie est à noter
qu'au sein de transports canada il ya
une absence de surveillance suffisante à
l'échelle nationale depuis la compagnie
ferroviaire à qui appartenait le train a
été dissoute
on a refermé le dossier
d' enquête publique permettrait aussi
de faire toute la lumière sur cette
tragédie zlap parlement de dany vite et
d'autres ailleurs
car il y en a eu d'autres depuis mais
l'antique on recense le canada de
nombreux déraillement majeur impliquant
le matières dangereuses dont au moins
sept trains qui transportaient également
du pétrole brut on a vu au manitoba en
saskatchewan
ça peut arriver dans une communauté
quelconque où il ya eu défaillance
chose que la négative alors la porte est
encore ouverte pour un autre mais quand
c'est un accident de cette nature oui un
accident important à mon avis oui si on
n'agit pas
c'est incontournable
l'ingénieur jean paul lacoursière est
une sommité mondiale en matière de
gestion de substances dangereuses
il ya du bon qui ont souffert donc payer
pour acter quantique aux normales
classifier le produit puis ensuite un
cheval qui était un déficit qui
essayaient de couper les coûts
puis est arrivé ce qui devait arriver
parce qu'on n'a tourné
que ça que ça se passe comme ça
[Musique]
ici à des jeux des vagues ont commencé à
bouger il ya des essieux qui ont enterré
ici un déraillement qui aurait pu être
bien plus grave le 12 octobre 2000 17 7
vallons d'un immense train de
marchandises des rails sur la berge de
la rivière des mille îles un accident
qui ébranle martin archambault quand je
suis parti en voiture avec une collègue
j'ai vu des dizaines de camions de
pompiers sur l'autoroute 25 en direction
nord est certes un camion avec une
embarcation à l'arrière fait le jeu se
pose qui est arrivé mais c'est gros
comment vous êtes centre ou
soulager un soulagés qui est peu
d'exclusion qui a pas eu de victimes qui
est pourri de les versements toxiques
mais en même temps ça met le paquet
question pourquoi le traire déraillé
qu'est ce qui s'est passé quand ça a
commencé à poser ses questions ben c'est
qu'il sait c'est que pas de réponse
c'est aussi simple que ça
martin archambault essaie depuis des
années de découvrir les causes de cet
accident frustré il nous a contacté pour
nous faire part de sa kite c'est que le
tri de la compagnie québec gatineau
transportait des matières dangereuses
notamment du propane ma demande était au
départ j'aimerais savoir ce qui s'est
passé mon but était avant le rapport
d'accident il a fait une demande d'accès
à l'information
allant même en audience pour plaider son
cas devant un juge mais sans succès la
copie n'est pas obligé de révéler cette
information se remettra en cause la
compétitivité ou la sécurité des
installations
donc la compagnie se cache derrière un
poteau de téléphone mais la locomotive
des pas il a cependant réussi à mettre
la main sur un autre document le compte
rendu confidentiel du service de
sécurité incendie de laval
le rapport était quand même un sac à
main pour la compagnie parce qu'on dit
que
que les enquêteurs donc la police de
laval ont pu rencontrer les opérateurs
du train et qui ont dit c'est une scène
d'accident grave donc ne rien bouger et
les gens la compagnie selon le rapport
on dit ont déplacé le coc motiver les
nos employés vont sonner chez vous
les points sont venus prendre des photos
des rails qui était abîmé quelques
kilomètres avant le déraillement la
police khan était pacifique ont refusé
l'accès
il ya plein de petites choses comme ça
que je me suis dit c'est l'omerta on
apprend aussi qu'il n'y avait aucune
procédure précise pour les cas de
matières dangereuses et que les équipes
spécialisées requises pour ce genre
d'intervention ne sont jamais arrivés
les policiers semblent avoir les mains
liées on affirme que c'est la compagnie
qui mènera sa propre enquête qui sont
juges et parties je considère qu'on fait
trop confiance aux compagnies 6e banques
font leur propre enquête sur leur propre
accident avec une opacité équivalente à
l'audace via des mails et l'on voit pas
cru là dedans
semaines peints québec gatineau nous
répond que leur action était justifie
plus que les sept wagons qui avait
déraillé n'était pas ce qu'ils
contenaient des matières dangereuses la
compagnie affirme avoir mis en place des
mesures correctives le canadien
pacifique lui nie avoir bloqué l'accès
aux policiers concernant lac mégantic il
dit que ses rails sont inspectés
régulièrement et qu'ils sont conformes à
des normes de sécurité élevées
les règles sont écrits par les
compagnies de chemin de fer transportant
ne reçoit que les avis et pelé
questionner ou tenter d améliorer mais
c'est les compagnies qui possède le
plein pouvoir
cette approche n'est pas limitée aux
compagnies ferroviaires les pipelines et
les camions qui transportent ces
substances ainsi que les établissements
qui en stock sont les premiers à assurer
la sécurité de leurs installations sous
une surveillance gouvernementale qui
selon les experts seraient déficiente
odyssée l'entreprise besson entreprises
qui est responsable
wade barça
mais on sait s'il n'ya pas d'inspection
on ne peut pas être
et ce sera surtout surveillée
lorsque le principal le besoin c'est les
bénéfices
[Musique]
bienvenue a obtenu patelin de 2000
personnes en montérégie un village cp
qui muni d'une caserne de pompiers de
magasin général et de quelques
entreprises agroalimentaires
tout ça en boarder d'un chemin de fer
étaient vraiment proches des villages
des populations
post l'église tout est collé collé collé
litres et paul bel art et sa conjointe
sont déménagés ici en 2015 un changement
de paysage nécessaire après un
traumatisme
ben nous on habitait un petit village
qui est juste aux côtés de mes gars et
la soirée de la catastrophe fall bédard
s'était retrouvé aux premières loges qui
pratiquent pense que toutes les 10
minutes 10 ou 15 minutes il y avait une
immense explosion
plusieurs foyers d'un incendie assez
majeur
le bruit aussi le cinéma d'aider des
réservoirs de fuel qui était sous
pression à cause du cru les gens
couraient partout que j'ai vu des gestes
plus jaloux
fait consciemment aussi dans ce conte
ici le propos est prêt pour cannes
l'hôpital seul sait ce qu au début je me
suis dit que ma conjointe parler du
train a dit pas encore un train pas
encore un train parce qu'on est juste
aux côtés d'un pont ferroviaire on a
choisi ici parce qu'on aime à plat selon
mme été détruits en un peu partout
mais après six ans de vie paisible ils
viennent d'apprendre qu'ils habitent
près d'une installation que la
municipalité juge désormais dangereux
j'ai le rapport d'expertisé qui a été
fait juste vous montrer le cercle rouge
sauce et la boule de feu
c'est
ce à peu près 50% du village
les petites semelles rouges c'est
pratiquement ici dans ma cour je le bats
les rues mais semble que c'est en plein
coeur d'un petit village comme ça c'est
mettait beaucoup de risques je trouve
depuis 2008 l'entreprise propane du
suroît fournit un service important à la
région c'est ici dans les installations
d'une autre compagnie nommée
distribution open que le train livre des
wagons remplis de propane marchandises
quittant se transférer vers des camions
citernes en processus qui s'appelle le
transvasement par station mobile
alors le clan qui avaient des activités
transvasement c'est là que ça se passait
là ça se passe ça ressemble à quoi il y
avait ou de voir qu'on stationner c'est
un dossier qui préoccupe les élus
municipaux mais c'est pas clôturé sous
et cancale bragon talent tout le monde
va aller le jeu voilà un taux de
joagroupe tout
il faut dire que distribution aptn a les
permis nécessaires et l'aval des
instances gouvernementales concernées
ces installations figure même sur la
page couverture de ce guide de la régie
du bâtiment du québec
mais en janvier 2021 le maire guy
lapointe et son équipe reçoivent une
analyse des risques liés à l'entreprise
qui leur présente des constats
inquiétants qu'est-ce que vous avez
découvert comme conséquences
potentielles certaines explosions je
dirais qu'il y avait à moitié c'est trop
au coeur du village hier il y aura
peut-être aussi selon la grosseur des
sports l'explosion puis notre caserne
des pompiers projet de l'eau à rapport
ça même temps une quinzaine dans la zone
rouge qu'ils seraient incapables de
fournir le débit d'eau nécessaire en cas
d'urgence cette analyse c'est
l'ingénieur jean paul lacoursière qu'il
a cosigné j'ai fait une première étude
qui a été soumise à la ville où je la
commande est de l'apport de nouvelles et
un permis de
d'exploitation
de l'entreprise en cause pourquoi à
cause de la proximité des gens il ya
potentiel de mortalité pour les
personnes non protégés qui sont exposés
qui sont exposés
malgré les mesures de sécurité en place
qui selon la compagnie vont au-delà de
ce qui est requis des incidents se sont
déjà produits sur le site des rapports
obtenus par enquêtes démontrent qu'en
2019 une voiture s'est enflammée sur la
propriété et en 2010 une fuite de
propane provenant des installations est
descendu dans les égouts sur les avis
étaient un égout pied à matthew goss pas
parce que ça rappe une allumette
remettons une table de scarlett o'hara
pu faire sauter la sortie de blood pâti
du villageois et quelques centaines de
résidants de obtenons montérégie ont eu
une bonne peur la nuit dernière il ne
s'agit pas du premier incident
impliquant des matières dangereuses a
obtenu le soutien d'une fuite d'ammoniac
à l' usine 6 2 transformations 2 le
havre a voulu que paul bédard est aussi
été témoin de cet événement à l'époque
il travaillait dans le centre de
réhabilitation du village
même année les pompiers sont venus nous
faut évacuer
les on est 100 personnes si on y lit
couettes ue tout ce qu'on voit que ce
qu'on fait même les ponts qui savaient
pas quoi faire avec nous le thé avec le
souvenir que j'ai de cette nuit là c'est
vraiment un m'as tu abandonné par ses
proches qu'on savait même pour gaver de
l'ammoniac questionne appréciée dit ben
coudon
varzécoises
soit compagnie cet hiver il ya eu un
lâcher prise à quelques portes les gens
sont dispo grave si tout est fait
sécuritaire mais s'il n'y a pas de
danger est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui est
déjà venu cueillir votre porte vous dire
bonjour dans la zone de danger
voici un plan d'évacuation non jamais
jamais
pour le moment apple mais là on n'a pas
à s'inquiéter le rapport de jean paul
lacoursière a eu son effet auprès de la
régie du bâtiment du québec la rbq mais
quand vous avez reçu les résultats
qu'est ce que vous avez fait on et
formula et vécu tout ça c'est de là que
la rbq amené à me jurez de passer à
table quelque chose alors les opérations
ont cessé les opérations ont cessé mais
l'entreprise conteste la décision la
commande est son propre rapport
d'expertisé qui jugent que le niveau de
sécurité du site est supérieure à la
moyenne et que les activités transaction
devrait continuer d'être autorisé devant
le tribunal de la rbq l'ingénieur
embauché par la compagnie dit que la
proche de jean paul lacoursière donne
trop d'importance aux conséquences
potentielles et négligent la faible
probabilité qu'un accident se produit
[Musique]
mais un troisième rapport d' analyse
celui là commandée par la régie du
bâtiment se range derrière jean paul
lacoursière et soulignent plusieurs
erreurs et omissions dans le rapport
commandé par la compagnie
cet affrontement d'ingénieurs découle du
fait que la loi québécoise ne dicte pas
de critères précis pour évaluer le
risque acceptable chacun est libre de
choisir ses références ce qui peut
donner les conclusions trade fair
défini peau c'est quoi une installation
sécuritaire
alors c'est autant pour qu'ils puissent
selon quels critères moi je peux ben ali
je vous vous dis c'est sécuritaire
l'installation il raconte les normes
accès existants
sont est incomplète médias contre les
énormes puis leur pratique semble
correct on met bien sur les épaules
maintenant le fonds ne devrait pas
revenir ses parois décide ici c'est
acceptable pour nous pour les citoyens
et à tellement de possibilités que
le résultat peut être très large donc il
faut pouvoir s'assurer et se donner un
standard pour dire que les titres
d'appréciation de l'est du réservoir de
propane
ou démoniaque coup d'éclat à montréal
c'est la même que celle à gaspé
mais que ce soit à montréal à gaspé où a
obtenu ce flou crée des situations
potentiellement dangereuses et force les
municipalités à faire des choix
déchirants comment vous vous sentez avec
tout ça
tu veux pas aller contre les autres
pascale fautrier de montréal spvm un peu
de vie dans
ces
c'est important pour le village c'est
peut-être
sur la 117 dans la réserve faunique la
vérendrye en direction de val d'or
les vestiges d'un incident qui aurait pu
avoir des conséquences dramatiques le 15
octobre 2020 vers 21h ont été appelés à
intervenir pour une remorque serait
impliqué dans un incendie dans le parc
de la vérendrye ou qu'ils avaient 360
qui
on a des photos
demant
d'à peu près d'ici qui on voit que c'est
le bon endroit parce que le boulou
identique on voit les cocons c'est un
feu confirmé à partir de pneus ça s'est
propagé à la remorque même près de vingt
mille kilos d'explosifs répartis dans
treize compartiments ont été soumis à
une chaleur intense les flammes exposé
au flop provoqué de la fumée et des gaz
toxiques et corrosives par le fait même
les pompiers ont évacué le périmètre de
1,6 km tâche relativement facile compte
tenu du secteur isolé les explosifs ont
brûlé sans déflagration on est sur une
autre pense canadienne c'est sûr que le
transport des matières dangereuses parce
quand même importante notre région nous
repartons vers val d'or mais à peine
quelques minutes plus tard cet accident
impliquant deux poids lourds dont un
contenant des matières dangereuses
toutefois la substance
non
pendant plus de dix heures la route est
paralysé
dans cette région le risque d'un
accident industriel impliquant des
matières dangereuses n'est jamais très
loin
[Musique]
éventuellement le ici le plan
d'urbanisme la ville haut à gauche de
cette ville jean-pierre tonnage
lacaunais de fond en comble il était
jusqu'à tout récemment le directeur du
service de sécurité incendie
est-ce que français qui il veut y avoir
de plus en plus d'industrie avec des
matières dangereuses qui vont
s'installer
autre co signer mines continuent ce
domaine louis saha prend des matières
c'est que la ville est au croisement de
plusieurs chemins où transitent
d'importantes quantités de produits
toxiques qui explose et qui
approvisionne les mines et les usines du
nord j'en garde de lac-mégantic système
à world series de quoi de sérieux
cinq majeur baldor faut jamais dire que
c'est pendant notre cour le zoo qu'ils
ont eue dans le court on pense à aux
victimes on pense à nos confrères
pompiers puis on pense aussi à comment
on a réagi face à éric hébert est le
nouveau directeur de service sécurité
incendie de val-d'or on n'avait pas
connaissance réellement de toutes les
substances qu'on en avait donc c'était
seuil était là oui on savait que nos
commerçants avec certains types de
produits mais sans plus on s'est aperçu
assez rapidement le cas vers une
croissance au niveau de ceux de cette
plaque tournante le qui devenait
important de s'y pencher tu devrais m'en
aller faire un inventaire de nos
produits
il ya quoi dans ces wagons soit ici si
tu probable le poteau d'horizon des noms
plus
fonctionnel futon sentir à pau un des
gros fournisseurs de la région un
distributeur de propane avait les permis
requis pour stocker la substance dans
des réservoirs sur son site il avait
aussi droit à quelques wagons retrait
mais le nombre de wagons sur le site ne
cessait d'augmenter au point que la
ville s'inquiétait de ne pas avoir les
ressources nécessaires pour gérer un
potentiel incident avec l'expansion qui
a pris s'arrêter impossible volume d'eau
étaient insuffisants pour tous protégés
l'iresa voix qui à vélo le pire scénario
ça serait bien voir dans deux programmes
explose et les projections l'eau la
partie résidentielle ici la plus proche
comme c'est beau ce maillot il tord
sketch une salade et il y aura des
projections l'eau avec pratiquement
jusqu'à l'hôpital à val-d'or de
particules de métal de jouer un rôle qui
pourrait se rendre jusqu'à nous au début
on a mis certaines limitations ou à
l'entreprise de mettre certains moyens
de protection et
on abri assez rapidement que
lamine fall qui n'avait pas le droit de
perso donc vous allez pouvoir d'assurer
la sécurité
exact exactement car en dépit de toutes
les matières dangereuses sur son
territoire val d'or n'avait pas
l'autorité d'imposer ce genre
d'exigences il y avait quand même une
réglementation qui existe un autre
transport au niveau de certains
ministères étaient pas automatique qu'on
l'avait soient les quantités ou la
transaction qui se faisait exactement
cet endroit pour avoir accès à ces
informations
la ville a entrepris un projet unique en
son genre une première pour la province
un règlement municipal lui permettant de
demander à toutes les industries sur son
territoire un inventaire de marchandises
dangereuses de même qu'une évaluation
des risques on examine ce temps ça c'est
assez rapide même si on fait une demande
la cour supérieure
de
la compagnie en question déjà soumise à
une foule d'exigence s'est opposé à
l'idée que la municipalité en ajoute le
cas s'est retrouvé devant les tribunaux
jusqu'en cour d'appel une saga qui au
total aura duré sept ans puis les jours
de notre entrevue
le juge a
donné son verdict comme quoi que le
règlement était valide mais des crimes
il y au moins il ya quelque chose qui
vaut ramon qui ramassent tous au pour
éviter qu'un lac-mégantic se reproduise
pour la sécurité des gens à l'eau
c'est fou qui les élisent un pas que ça
parle je peux vous dire qu'on était
suivi de près par plusieurs autres
municipalités mrc
communauté métropolitaine aussi de
québec mais toutes les municipalités
n'ont pas nécessairement les ressources
pour développer leur propre règlement et
même si c'était le cas cette approche à
la pièce pourrait mener à un chaos de
mesures disparates
une autre solution favorisée par
certaines municipalités et le comité
mixte municipalité industrie et on débat
et on veut regarder quelles sont nos
hauts risques puis on va s'asseoir que
la municipalité les services d'urgence
les parkings près d'ici on s'assoit
aussi avec lady d fonctionner depuis on
re développer des plans d'urgence puis
on va aussi développer des plans de
communication parce que il ya du monde
qui gît au tour mais la clé selon les
intervenants interrogés demeure une
meilleure réglementation provinciale
nous avons mené un sondage auprès des
municipalités du québec
220 ont répondu de ce chiffre 55% nous
ont dit qu'elle ne croit pas être au
courant de toutes les matières
dangereuses toki par les entreprises sur
leurs territoires et 12% des répondants
disent avoir des matières dangereuses à
proximité de résidences et de lieux
vulnérables
un pourcentage qui pourrait être plus
élevé étant donné que plus du quart ont
choisi de ne pas répondre à cette
question
non c'est pour tout ça c'est pas tout et
sociale d'un usain sa voix qu'est ce que
tu as plutôt que les produits chimiques
plutôt ton cpo
c'est difficile c'est ça c'est notre
sondage maison indique également que
seule une minorité des gens qui habitent
à proximité de ces installations
auraient reçu un plan d'urgence de la
part de ces entreprises est ce que les
industriels vont cogner à la porte
qui est censé aviser les citoyens
zoo sont censés traîne un travail là
dessus ne font pas une faune pour les
gens doivent savoir à quels risques sont
exposés qui s'est associée la
responsabilité d'aller en veut
ceci change quoi ça commence sûrement
par les mines spect hinchey
il faut que les directives de
la basse et le fédéral a son rôle à
jouer
il ya beaucoup de jeunes et qui qui est
une sensibilisation plus grand de
ça c'est très très très bon est-ce que
les gens voudraient tout l'entend
on s'habitue on tombe petite routine
même année on s'habitue aussi qu'est-ce
qui circulent autour de nous on s'est
peut-être no kill dans ring
[Musique]
en 1984 la ville de bhopal en inde est
frappé par une catastrophe une
monumentale
[Musique]
une fuite de gaz toxique s'échappant de
l'usiné de iulian carbide un
distributeur américain de produits
chimiques
la façon dont il a fait les personnes
étaient allés saluer agi avec l'eau il a
détruit le corps le mucus complètement
bully dissoute par le gaz est donc ce
fut probablement prêt
atroce
et
il faut pas que ça se reproduise
3500 personnes ont péri presque sur le
champ mais plusieurs sont mortes dans
les jours et les semaines même les
années suivantes au total le bilan se
rapprocherait de vingt mille morts avec
un demi million de blessés et des
séquelles qui sont encore sentir
aujourd'hui
jean paul lacoursière travailler pour
une union carbide à montréal à l'époque
de la tragédie c'est un moment qui a
totalement changé sa vie et qui a changé
la gestion des matières dangereuses à
travers le monde qu'est ce qui a changé
comment les américains ont certainement
fait
ils ont
passé une loi qui s'appelle le règle
tous nos actes les gens doivent savoir
ce qu'il ya dans les usines ils ont
changé le clean air act
ce qui leur a permis d'introduire
un règlement qui oblige les
les entreprises à avoir des programmes
de prévention spécifiques pour les
accidents majeurs l'on parle des états
unis et le canada lui a fait quoi
cavada lui
il a un peu été
consultés
et attendu attendu et a créé un comité
qui s'appelle le conseil canadien des
accidents industriels majeurs ça ça l'a
conduit à des lignes directes ce sont
des lignes directrices donc c'est pas
obligatoire
aujourd'hui selon les experts le
problème n'est plus nécessairement un
manque de réglementation mais plutôt un
manque de cohésion et si j'en ai
québec et au canada environnement canada
le professeur gervais souci a été
mandatée par le ministère de la sécurité
publique pour faire l'état de la
situation et proposer des améliorations
une des difficultés c'est que il ya
plusieurs niveaux intervenant au niveau
municipal le niveau provincial le niveau
fédéral le niveau international avec les
noms et chacun des fois fait sa propre
réglementation utilisent des définitions
différentes qui fait que pour le commun
des mortels
fait dit si des fois de se retrouver
alors toutes ces différentes
réglementations l'oeil ne sont pas
nécessairement harmoniser non à son
souffle et malheureusement c'est une des
difficultés qui rend que les petites
entreprises et ben sont découragés de
deux ça dérangeait pas faire ça parce
que je sais pas comment c'est yves bot
est un ingénieur qui a aidé les
entreprises à se conformer à la
réglementation j'ai crié lui il ya de
l'ammoniac ou de la décade 10e le
règlement fédéral spi dans son coin il
fallait qu'il fasse un plan de relance
environnementaux je n'ai jamais entendu
parler
ces gens là ils sont totalement dépassé
par celui cet étourdissant cafouillage
de réglementation crée des défis
importants pour les compagnies qui
doivent se plier aux exigences une étude
fédérale menée après l'explosion de
beyrouth a révélé que la réglementation
qui encadre le nitrate d'ammonium au
canada n'est pas toujours évidente et
peut porter à confusion
ce qui pourrait mener à des situations
de non conformités involontaire on
souligne que les stocks de moins d'une
tonne ne sont pas soumis à des exigences
de sécurité spécifiques ils se
retrouvent parfois dans des zones
urbaines densément peuplés
au québec cependant certains experts
s'inquiètent du fait que tout un pan de
la loi sur la sécurité civile
provinciale est inopérant on encore une
loi dont les articles précis paul soppo
mis en vigueur en est à découvert à
découvrir parfaitement la loi sur la
sécurité civile adoptée en 2001 comptait
plusieurs articles qui aurait mieux
encadrer les matières dangereuses mais
qui ne sont jamais entrées en vigueur
pourquoi ça s'est pas fait d'après nos
jardins du ministère juste mais c'est un
trou béant
ya pas de l'année ce petit repos
notamment toutes les formations dont
elle a besoin et en plus y'a pas
d'autres critères et qui définit qu'est
ce qui est acceptable comme risque
des documents internes obtenus par
enquête démontre que ces enjeux
préoccupe le ministère de la sécurité
publique on s'inquiète que dans
l'éventualité d'un sinistre majeur le
ministère pourrait être tenu responsable
et on souligne qu'en raison de la non
mise en oeuvre de ces articles le
gouvernement se trouve en infraction de
sa propre loi une loi qui l'obligent à
prévenir et à réduire les risques et
qu'il pourrait s'exposer à des recours
judiciaires
difficile de brosser le portrait complet
de tous les stocks de matières
dangereuses au québec ou au canada les
sites qui entrepose des quantités
importantes sont sensés et répertorie
par environnement canada et pour des
raisons de sécurité nationale ce
registre est désormais confidentiel
accessible seulement à certaines
personnes désignées au sein d'une
municipalité
le sondage maison pourtant révélé que 69
% des répondants ne connaissent pas
l'existence de ce registre ou bien ils
ignorent comment et accèder sociale est
la terre complètement je m'attendais pas
à ce que j'allais pas la cycline qu'ils
étaient beaucoup mieux et formique ce
messie de son repos mais il faut les
informer
dans les deux dernières années seulement
40 du responsable de la sécurité
publique ont demandé à consulter ce
registre 40,2 sur un total de plus de
5000 municipalités à travers le canada
et selon nos experts cette liste de
matières dangereuses serait également
incomplète
je veux dire tout un point intéressant
on n'a pas de système
efficace pour répertorier les accidents
- comme ingénieur je veux savoir
pourquoi c'est arrivé à tel endroit
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait qu'il tape
encore des jeux programme de trouver les
experts le répète il est difficile de
s'améliorer quand nos erreurs ne sont
pas bien répertoriés par ministère à ses
banques de données mais sont souvent
faut travailler avec la loi d'accès à
l'information
donc c'est pas évident donc apprendre
des erreurs du profit d'incidence du
procès c'est extrêmement difficile à
l'heure actuelle dans notre structure au
québec qu'au canada
pourtant les erreurs du passé les
souvent de vives cicatrices chez ceux
qui ont été affectés c'est très fort et
mégantic le village au conflit c'est
beaucoup plus grave si l'on attendait 6
mai l'osce
à chaque explosion t'es sûr que s'ils
reprennent
les opérations d de propane joue un jour
garder leur aide leur est ouverte
constamment france
le cas de distribution obtenu est
toujours devant les tribunaux le futur
des opérations de transvasement reste
incertain mais s'ils ont la permission
de reprendre moi tant que membre à temps
qu'est confié qu on est alors faite de
bois mais le matin s'ils arrivent de
quoi je pense lafonta vous revenez à un
roumain dont la sbq que voilà et remis
le permis à distribution octobre un
kamikaze en a tous
rêvé que nature je pense que
la rbq nous dit qu'une révision
réglementaire est en cours même réponse
du ministère de la sécurité publique qui
admet qu'il existe bel et bien des
lacunes dans la loi et qui mène
actuellement des consultations dans le
but de présenter un nouveau projet de
loi en 2000 m le travail de gervais
soucis et de son équipe s'insère dans
cette démarche mais l'ingénieur souligne
que la prévention peut être difficile à
vendre des accidents majeurs avec une
matière dangereuse c'est que c'est des
événements qui sont pas très grandes
conséquences mais qui arrive très peu
souvent un peu comme quand on le fait
pour la pandémie
[Musique]
au revoir donc au repos sont toutes les
budgets des ministères
aucun doute qu'il ya des pressions
exercées par
l'industrie
pour alléger la réglementation on est
beaucoup demandé
et
par quand le contrepoids n'existait pas
pour écoute pouces et d'un seul côté
mais il faut pour obtenir l'équilibré il
faut avoir quelqu'un qui pose à notre
côté aussi je pense qu'on va toujours
devoir transporter des matières
dangereuses
au canada comme ailleurs dans le monde
parce que nos industries en ont besoin
nous-mêmes ans on en consomme sauf qu'il
faut peut-être abandonné le
projet suivant le pétrole aller vers de
nouvelles énergies renouvelables et tout
à l'heure on en a besoin on pour lutter
contre les changements climatiques on
aura besoin
l'hydrogène l'hydrogène serait très
inflammables
il faut apprendre à gérer ses produits
mais ils sont nécessaires et on a aussi
besoin
de projets de produits chimiques très
sophistiqués pour produire des panneaux
solaires ça vient pas du ciel
non mais il faut
il faut maîtriser ces risques
il faut que tout le monde en soit
conscient
et fasse des joints
[Musique]